I think to be better prepared for
fundraising process every founder need
to speak to other founders that
have gone through the process.
Learn from them about their experiences,
the do's and
don'ts of what worked and what didn't.
It's really about having a few things
ready when you kick of the process.
A, you need the materials.
You need the deck, you need any Excel
financials, everything that you can
that sort of you can share with
an investor at the right time.
Second, you need to practice your pitch.
The pitch is not 20 minute conversation,
it's really being able to tell your
story succinctly, in an effective way
and for that you need to practice a lot.
And finally, you need to really
figure out who it is you're pitching.
What type of investors
are you looking for?
Who are they?
Will they invest in
your type of business?
Do they have the passion for it?
All investors don't
invest in everything,
you have to find the right ones for
you, for your business.